hey everyone its Warren and the recent
brothers have recently spoken out about
Avengers endgame they spoke out about
Avengers endgame in a new interview with
Empire magazine in this interview they
talked a little bit about the state of
the universe after Thanos has snap and
the state of Thanos after the snap they
also go over the runtime of Avengers in
game as well so I'll be talking about
all of these in this video also if you
would like to enter my giveaway for your
chance to win a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero so to start
off let's talk about the length of the
movie previously the risa brothers have
teased that Avengers in game is
currently sitting at 3 hours long but
this was before editing and they said
that there was a lot of editing left so
that didn't necessarily mean that the
film would be at 3 hours however a lot
of time has passed between then and now
and in this interview they said that
there's a high probability that this
movie will clock in at around 3 hours
it's a big movie with a lot of story so
now it's looking like Avengers in game
will in fact be around 3 hours long
which will be Marvel's longest movie the
researchers then talked about the effect
that the decimation had on the universe
according to the Russo brothers Thanos
collecting all of the Infinity stones
and performing the snap had an
unintended effect on the universe that
Thanos didn't plan on here's what
Anthony Russo had to say these are
characters in a story moving forward
where infinity war happened the entire
universe experienced the same fate and
has been brought together by this
experience so everybody in the universe
all beings in the universe were affected
the same exact way half of their
populations got wiped out by Thanos so
it seems like in Avengers endgame all of
these different species are going to be
searching for the reason that this has
happened and it seems like everybody is
going to figure out that it was Thanos
with all of the Infinity stones and
judging from what Anthony Russo said
once everybody figures this out Thanos
is in for some trouble because the whole
entire universe is going to unite and
try to undo the snap this could actually
open up Avengers endgame to introduce
some new characters and the Russo
brothers themselves have said that we're
going to see some new
characters that we've never seen in the
MCU before but we've seen in the comics
and what Anthony Russo said is sort of
setting that up so we could possibly see
some other characters being introduced
the Eternals have been talked about for
a long time now
and Kevin Feige has actually teased Nova
now these are just speculation but it
sounds like the whole entire universe is
going to be teaming up against Thanos
which means we'll be seeing some new
characters so that's what the recent
brothers had to say about the state of
the universe after the decimation but
they also had some things to say about
fan OSIS state after the decimation as
far as Thanos the mad Titan is concerned
here's what Joe Russo had to say about
his state after the decimation he's
succeeded in the thing he has set out to
do he's done he did it he's retired so
in Avengers endgame at least in the
beginning Thanos isn't really going to
be doing much for years and years and
years since his home planet of Titan was
destroyed and his people became extinct
Thanos has been going throughout the
universe wiping out half of the
populations of each planet he's gone to
in an attempt to balance the universe so
he can save the universe this is what
Thanos has been doing for years until he
found out about the Infinity stones
Thanos realized that if he collected all
the Infinity stones he could simply
balance the universe with the snap of
his fingers which we all know he did in
all six domes I could sue to snap my
fingers
we would all cease to exist I call that
you see so what Thanos set out to do
many many many years ago he has now
accomplished it so he's done he's no
longer going playing at the planet to
try and balance the universe he did it
and that's why we see fan OHS on a farm
at the end of Avengers infinity war and
that's why we see him on a farm in the
Avengers end game teaser trailer but of
course at the end of infinity war it did
safe an oath will return that means that
something is going to have to happen to
get Thanos to come out of retirement and
the whole universe uniting together to
go against Thanos to undo his snap will
probably do the trick and if Thanos
starts to see some of the Infinity
stones disappearing from the Infinity
Gauntlet that will probably do the trick
as well so that's it for everything the
Russo brothers said about Avengers in
game in their recent interview what do
you all think about the universe uniting
together and about fan o's being retired
who do you think will show up in
avengers endgame and what do you think
is going to get phantos to come out of
retirement let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and of course
don't forget to subscribe a comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers endgame
as always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]